E aí
[Música]
a geração especialista em relações
saudáveis eu quero saber se você conhece
uma pessoa que passou antes investido
tempo e dinheiro em se conhecer para
isso fazendo várias terapias Santo
convencionais com a políticas mas que
quando você olha para a vida dessa
pessoa continua igual ela vive tendo os
mesmos tipos de problemas Sabe aquela
mulher que sempre faz terapias vai em
retiros e atrai o mesmo tipo de
relacionamento e vive reclamando das
mesmas questões Pois então eu era essa
mulher eu cair na armadilha do
autoconhecimento quando era criança eu
olhava para o céu estrelado à noite e eu
pensava tudo que eu mais quero nessa
vida é encontrar um grande amor um
grande amor que eu possa demonstrar
e tudo que eu tenho para dar e que eu
também possa receber poesias cartas
viagem surpresas cantoria serenatas eu
imaginava tudo isso e o meu sonho de um
amor recíproco e verdadeiro não tinha um
machucado frustrações era paz era um
amor intenso e verdadeiro chegou minha
adolescência E aí o relacionamento atrás
dos outros só machucados era isso que
tinha no meu coração muito machucado eu
fui muito ferida e também ferir porque
quem fere está ferido e quem está ferido
fere e eu me encaixava nesse padrão
também então eu fiz muitos
relacionamentos em que eu me senti a
rejeitada abandonada trocada isso doía
demais tantos outros quando a pessoa
é incrível é um rejeitado abandonada e
trocava dar bode eu não gostava quando a
relação é gostosa parecia que aquela
coisa doentia que me fazer sofrer e
ajoelhar cantando Sertanejo sofrido eram
que me atendia eu acreditava que aquilo
era o amor verdadeiro passei anos presa
em ciclo de relações que me machucavam
até que chegou um dia que eu não
aguentava mais sofrer a dor era física
meu peito podia uma dor que eu não
conseguia falar eu chorava e posição
fetal no escuro na minha cama agarrando
o meu travesseiro incontáveis vezes eu
já tinha feito isso E aí eu decidi usar
todo dinheiro que eu comecei no meu
trabalho a ganhar né quando eu comecei a
ensaiar usavam todo meu dinheiro e tudo
que eu fazendo meu trabalho para ser
promovida era para conseguir renda para
investir entrar isso
e pias variadas Retiro de
autoconhecimento tudo que eu queria era
adquirir Inteligência Emocional
autoconhecimento para conseguir o meu
objetivo viver um relacionamento
saudável me sentindo amada e podendo
amar também bom foi aí que eu cair na
armadilha do autoconhecimento e eu vou
te contar como que isso aconteceu nas
rodas de amigas do final de semana eu
passava contando todas as minhas
questões de relacionamento que não davam
certo não cinco terapias que eu fazia
durante a mesma semana e nos retiros dos
finais de semana que eu fazia a mesma
coisa eu comentava tudo que me machucado
por quê que me machucava o que que eu
tava repetindo que não era legal e que
eu já sabia mas que eu tava continuando
batendo na mesma tecla e eu vivia
falando de tudo que me machucava dos
meus traumas quando eu descobri que eu
estava repetindo todo o ambiente que eu
vivi na minha em
e vai com a minha mãe viu os
relacionamentos E aí então que eu falava
sobre isso sem parar eu estava amada
alma decorando o fundo do meu poço com
os melhores móveis os melhores
aperitivos eu fiz morada no fundo do
posto de tanto falar sobre os meus
problemas sobre as minhas questões eu me
tornei mestra desse fundo do poço fui
morar lá era só disso que eu falava e a
sensação é como se eu tivesse resolvendo
eu achava que falar sobre os meus
problemas racionalizado dos deles
colocá-los em caixinhas os meus
machucados os relacionamentos tudo que
eu fazia de errado nos nas minhas
relações se eu falasse sobre isso eu
achava que ia resolver e eu passei anos
investindo em terapias pessoas para me
dizer o que que tava certo que estava
errado em mim
e eu precisava de pessoas sejam
tarólogos pessoas que equilibravam meu
campo aurico psicólogos todos os tipos
de Terapias que eu conheço até hoje eu
já investi
e eu queria que as pessoas me dissesse o
que fazer e na verdade eu saia de cada
uma dessas terapias com diagnósticos o
que que tava errado e eu já sabia eu
voltava a conversar sobre aquilo em
todas as outras terapias então enquanto
eu ia não acupunturista na segunda-feira
e ele me falava Fernanda você tem que
resolver tal questão com os seus pais e
tu eu usava esse essa conversa lá na
minha psicóloga da quinta-feira E aí eu
ficava sempre no círculo fazer a
namorada decorando o meu fundo do poço
a buscar uma solução na minha cabeça
tava E aí eu estava sempre falando dos
meus problemas buscando solucionar
através de uma racionalização através de
uma organização
Ah mais tarde eu descobri que não
adiantava organizar decorar muito menos
morar no fundo do poço para mudar a
minha vida
e foi ali sabe como que eu descobri isso
eu tava saindo da minha psicóloga nesta
tarde de quinta-feira e eu falei assim
eu não tive para nada realmente eu sou
um caso perdido eu estou esperando de
problemática eu não tenho consciência
e tudo que eu sei eu sei que tá errado
você que não deve repetir eu sei a fonte
que que muda porque é que ninguém me
fala o que eu preciso fazer eu nunca
achei ninguém que me dissesse exatamente
o passo a passo que eu precisava tomar
seguir vou acordar no dia seguinte vai
fazer o quê Para Viver um relacionamento
saudável para não mais entrar em
relações se machucavam para não mais
dispensar pessoas que me amavam e querer
pessoas que não me valorizavam o que
precisava fazer era tudo que eu queria
isso é o que eu buscava eu queria a
resposta o caminho não importa o que era
eu só queria seguir um passo a passo
ninguém me disse assim sempre me
apontavam os erros e eu comecei a ficar
viciada em ouvir as pessoas me dizerem
que estava errado em mim
Oi e eu continuava contando isso para as
minhas amigas e para os outros
terapeutas e aí realmente chegou esse
dia desta quinta-feira à tarde que eu
desmoronei era pior sensação a sensação
de que eu era um nada nessa época eu
estava atraindo vários relacionamentos
nenhum deles as pessoas valorizavam
é porque te conto a Minha autoestima
estava tão baixa porque eu achava que eu
não conseguiu solucionar minha vida
resolver os meus problemas por mais que
eu tivesse investido todo meu tempo todo
meu dinheiro não vale a pena porque de
fácil eu era tudo errado
o problema então a minha última ficou
tão baixa eu me sentia tão valorizada
que eu só conseguia atrair pessoas para
me provarem que eu era desvalorizada
mesmo que eu não tinha nenhum valor que
o número esse um amor verdadeiro ele e
era esse tipo de relacionamento que eu
tava traindo para minha vida e o
objetivo de toda essa jornada do
autoconhecimento era o que a Taís do
Central relacionamento saudável e era
tudo que não estava acontecendo
se você consegue entender como eu me
sentir E aí eu vou te contar o que que
aconteceu quando eu relutei porque foi
minha indignação uma indignação as
indignada que ninguém dizia o que fazer
e eu falei eu me escuro eu você essa
pessoa que vai me dizer o que fazer eu
acabo de decidir aqui agora que eu
soubesse que era de mim e não importa o
cão errado isso pode dar eu vou tentar
porque aqui nesse jeito que eu não
aguento mais ficar então foi que eu fui
lá no meu fundo do poço peguei tudo que
eu tinha decorado joguei num saco e
subir para o alto de uma luta dentro de
mim era essa sensação e eu iluminei tudo
tudo tudo tudo e eu comecei a entender
que eu precisava fazer exatamente ao
contrário do que eu sempre via fazendo
Principalmente nos relacionamentos
o incomodava
e eu que sempre dava dava dava dava tudo
que eu queria que eu podia que eu não
podia para provar que eu era boa o
suficiente para pessoa me aprovar e me
amar e não rejeitar e não vai abandonar
pelo amor de Deus para não sofrer eu
quero essa pessoa que precisava de
aprovação para me sentir amada tempo
inteiro e descobri que eu tava
desequilibrando de nome de dar e receber
do universo então eu falei seu sempre do
do máximo do meu amor relacionamentos
agora eu vou aceitar receber
e foi muito desafiador porque a primeira
vez que apareceu na minha frente a
oportunidade de eu me relacionar a
recebendo ao invés da da que dá né que
que eu falo quando eu digo dar fazer
todas as surpresas que você pode
imaginar nesse mundo relevar todos os
meus as minhas vontades próprias em prol
da vontade das pessoas que eu tava
ficando e eu não tinha mais poder
pessoal eu sempre fazia a vontade das
outras pessoas que você estava pensando
em como eu podia surpreender essa outra
pessoa é então eu sempre tava colocando
uma energia em prol do outro para pessoa
me amar de volta e aí eu resolvi
aprender a ficar quietinha e receber no
próximo relacionamento porque se eu
vivia fazendo de um jeito não tava dando
certo então eu ia fazer exatamente ao
contrário porque eu tinha decidido que
eu ia ser a minha própria mestra E aí eu
faço nada alma é que aí eu descobri como
se livrar da armadilha de
autoconhecimento
é porque eu achava que me alto
conhecendo eu ia me curar mas eu entendi
nesse dia que não autoconhecimento não
significa átrio porque não existe
transformação série ação hoje eu vivo um
relacionamento saudável hoje eu vivo um
amor recíproco e verdadeiro porque eu
aprendi a fazer diferente porque eu
entendi o fundo do meu coração na dor e
na indignação que se eu não percorresse
novos caminhos eu não veria novas
paisagens
a gratidão